should auld acquaintance be forgot and
never brought to mind should auld
acquaintance be forgot in days of auld
lang syne it occurs to me that I have no
idea what that song means and instead of
going to a DVD and figuring out what it
means for myself I'm going to assume for
the purposes of this video but all
Mind's on means something along the
lines of good Hank and John make more
videos in 2009 and the answer I think
should be guessed so I would like to
take you all back back far far into the
past so far into the past in which I
made a video two years ago in which I
didn't know how to make videos but I did
it anyway but with something like this
hey John I guess you've heard by now
auto power off still some glitches to
work out by now you have received my
message that we will no longer be
communic but well actually we will be
communicating through textual means you
can see my eye and my eye last night I
sent you an email I wasn't in lake tahoe
but this is footage from a party in Lake
Tahoe that I was at two years ago New
Year's Eve in which I will tell you
about Brotherhood 2.0 point 0.9 every
Sunday for the next year John you will
send me video and would you tell me
about some current news event that you
think is vitally important but I am
probably blissfully ignorant of cuz I
actually really like it when you do that
I think that's one of the coolest things
that we've done in Brotherhood Jubilee
know because you know blissful ignorance
is great and everything but it's nothing
compared to the crushing weight of the
truth I expect those videos to be good
comprehensive and in-depth and if you
want to eat toilet paper or smear peanut
butter all over your face that's fine
too
every Tuesday one of us will send the
other one a video blog of some sort you
can really just do whatever we want to
on Tuesdays every other Wednesday I will
perform an original Hank green song song
Wednesdays are back and then later in
the week maybe there will be another
video of some kind it would be a
surprise because I think some people
like the surprise aspect of the last
year whereas those people like the
structure so now you get structure and
surprise if one of us fails to keep up
these responsibilities we will be
punished I finished this email cross my
heart hope to die and I may very well be
required to stick a needle in my eyes
the kind of punishment I'm talking about
does that make us crazy probably a
little bit more complicated than the
first use rules turns out but there you
have it at least one vlog per week
sometimes two sometimes three news on
Sunday and songs every other Wednesday
so a little bit more structure for the
people who are looking for more
structure and more videos all around
because everybody unanimously wanted
more videos also of course there will be
more blog TV appearances and there are
plenty of open days for us doing
whatever the Frick we want to and I hope
that you will be down with us doing
whatever the Frick we want to because
there's nothing like doing whatever the
Frick I want to do as long as I'm doing
it with you done I'm fairly certain that
I will see you tomorrow happy freakin
New Year